[Music]
laughs
at the other turn I
oh oh okay okay
it's just been over two weeks since we
brought uh Josiah home
and it's been going great you know it's
an infant it's a newborn in the house
you know I feel like it's our like it's
it's my Niche like I that's this is
where I want to be it is there's nothing
I'd want to be doing other than hanging
out with three little kids
I have to say it
fine what's been your favorite part
about being a big brother
okay I'm good at helping Josiah huh yeah
pretty much all of my immediate family
has met Josiah now my mom's my dad and
um my siblings but we don't have plans
for Karen dimitro side
that still hasn't been any recognization
from Karen or my dad like they still
think they did nothing wrong which is
like I don't see how Karen doesn't see
this like my dad put her in a situation
also where it's like you got into family
business here your family is always
going to be like
it's going to be different than what
someone else rubs you the wrong way but
I don't excuse my dad like I hold my dad
responsible for that breakdown in that
relationship
okay
[Music]
Only Daddy can you say that yeah what
who makes you the authority Jackson let
her let her up oh and he holds his hand
yeah look at this I can never deny Matt
and Karen that they were amazing to us
that they helped us through many times I
mean they the kids loved them but no
matter what when you have two adults and
there's kids involved if those two
adults don't get along well
the relationship with the kid is going
to suffer
[Music]